voilà une nouvelle qui est intéressante
je ne recevoir tout nouveau colis alors
je pense qu'il s'agit des nouveaux
iphone iphone 12 mini iphone 12 pro mac
ce n'est pas encore la certitude mais je
suis quasiment sûr donc on va c'est
d'ouvrir ensemble on va regarder ça on
va comparer bien évidemment les formats
et les tailles notamment par rapport à
l'iphone 12 pro et par rapport à
l'iphone douche de cette année comme ça
j'aurai quatre nouveaux iphone de ce
deuxième semestre 2000 va pas oui je
voulais déjà dit c'est ta nea peut déjà
sortie d'une nouvelle version de son
iphone est ce qu'ils sont ils plus tôt
dans l'année pas moins de 5 iphone santé
cette année c'est une première chez
apple c'est vraiment énorme
on va donc se faire un tour complet des
iphone je vous sortir normalement je
crois que c'est demain matin à vidéo
test de l'iphone 12 pro s'ensuivra la
thèse de l'iphone 12 iphone 12 promax
l'iphone 12 min chacun a ses
particularités on regardera s'emballer
peluches et puis on a également parlé il
ya quelques jours de l'iphone watch
series 6 11 paragraphe est beau jour de
l'iphone watts c est ce qui m ont ployé
que ce train de tester actuellement
parlera également des nouveaux ipad il
ya plein de choses à raconter qu'ils
sont assez dingue là que tu ne s'arrête
pas là bien évidemment aussi de
smartphones sous android de plein de
trucs différents de textes quoi c'est
vachement cool
bon je vous invite à vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà fait vous cliquez sur le
petit bouton rouge qui est juste en
dessous comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera une
maintenance mais derrière il regarde ça
tout de suite
alors je crois va s'ouvrir par là
regardez-moi ça j'avais vu juste
qu'est ce qu'on a à l'intérieur iphone
les heures où elle est c'est quoi ça ah
oui tu un portefeuille en cuir hockey
jean gadras dans quelques jours et je
vous en ferai le mc saïda charger pour
venir recharger directement c'est très
très cool ils m'ont mis des coques alors
on a quoi là on a une coque en silicone
pour le mini ok j'ai une coque en cuir
pour le pro max et là je vais avoir les
boîtes avec les smartphones et de voir
ça on va commencer par mini parce que je
suis vraiment curieux de voir à quoi
ressemble effectivement le format mini
d'apple cette année avec la boîte déjà
les critiques il ne serait ce qu ont ces
boîtes là parce qu'ici ils sont dans
l'obligation de vous mettre vos
écouteurs c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous leur prouve
alors il s'y attendait le max le max le
max par où ils souffrent ici tac
toujours très simple à ouvrir ça marche
pour moi c'est joli déjà ne serait ce
que comme ça la différence de taille à
les vrais m'ont massif c'est vraiment
énorme
on va commencer par le mini enfin je
vous ai déjà dit les bonnes boxing chez
apple c'est vraiment plus craquant ouah
ouah c'est vraiment un mini modèles
regardez-moi ça à la prise en main c'est
vraiment tout petit c'est hyper hyper
impressionnant alors tout de suite qu'on
compare par rapport au match et je pense
que je vais pas être wah wah wah fait de
voir ah ouais
oh la vache ah ouais ça n'a rien à la
différence a dit ding
c'est absolument dingue alors c'est vrai
que bon ça c'est un truc qui est
vraiment énorme
et moi j'aime bien c'est conforme à
parce que c'est vraiment hyper hyper
confort ces minuscules regardez la
différence si je viens de mettre au
milieu le 12 et le douce pro mini 12 12
pro 12 pronax c'est hyper hyper hyper
impressionnant
il ya des vraies différences en fait
cette année chez apple qui ont été
instaurées notamment entre le 12 et le
12 progrès que vous avez une vraie
différence au niveau des optiques a pas
partout mais on va se battre sans
quelques jours il ya une différence là
dessus on a effectivement ici on le voit
sur les deux premiers le mini et le 12
et bien deux capteurs photo deux modules
photo pardon devrais je plutôt dire ici
on en a trois avec la caméra lidar pour
faire toute la réalité augmentée de la
mesure et compagnie on va regarder
toutes les différences on en parle dans
quelques jours on tourne ici sur la puce
à 14 bionique on est de la perte de tous
les côtés ça c'est très très cool et moi
je suis vraiment foot ce petit format
c'est vraiment me lire regarder même par
rapport à l'iphone 12 tendent à les
formations a strictement rien à voir
l'épaisseur me semble être la même mais
la hauteur or c'est fou et surtout par
rapport au max ah ouais là on est
vraiment mais vraiment dans un autre
monde
d'un côté et l'autre à ces dingos
d'ailleurs ça des smartphones qu'il faut
vraiment venir penser à protéger vous
avez soit les coques de protection
d'apple
vous avez le mcs save deux compatibles
sinon vous avez les produits de mon
partenaire rinne
schild alors je voulais montrer aussi
ultérieurement vous avez des protections
d'écran il y en a pour le mini en a pour
le pro vous allez retrouver notamment
pour les 12 et 12 pro ça c'est super
vous avez le mode enix qui va venir vous
l'entouré pour garder votre dos visibles
ça c'est super des crasses garde enix
pour le mini krach garde enix pour le 12
et le 12 pro on a le mot des knicks
également pour le minime et s'il pouvait
venir changer les couleurs et tout cas
plein plein de possibilités josemi les
liens en bas de la description ce que
vous avez une remise avec le code de
monsieur gros tout est en bas aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil puis vous
avez ensuite la solide suite pour le 12
et 12 prouve que ces mêmes formats vous
avez la solide suite pour le 12 min
enfin y'en a plein il y en a plein de
tous les côtés je vous ai mis le code en
bas dans la description pour venir
protéger votre smartphone grâce à rhinau
fini ça c'est très très très cool
une fois de plus je reviens pas de cette
différence de formats je sais pas lequel
je vais garder en smartphones principal
peut-être le max même si les très grands
l'année dernière j'ai regardé le 11
promax pendant quasiment un an
je trouvais quand même très grand mais
par contre extrêmement pratique pour le
visionnage
c'était ce qu'on avait mieux et on va
beaucoup plus loin en termes de photos
dont je vais vous le tester vous dirait
vraiment la différence entre le 12 pro
et 12 pro mac d'ici quelques jours est
par contre sûr que ce mini il est
vraiment cool ce tout petit format s'est
prise en main elle est dingue et c'est
des choses qu'on ne retrouvait pas en
tout cas chez apple depuis un petit
moment à voir si on aime vraiment les
petits smartphones et si on aime à ios
vous avez l'iphone et ceux de deuxième
génération qui est sorti il ya quelques
temps qui très bien très performant
celui là il al'avantage en plus d'avoir
une double optique donc ça c'est super
on se teste ça d'ici quelque chose dont
nous invite à rester connectés comme ça
vous saurez tout plein de jolies
nouvelle plein de nouveautés et puis en
plus ce soir encore une nouvelle keynote
d'apple il n'arrête pas il se
révolutionne apple il change tous les
prophètes probablement du coc vide pour
travailler différemment peut-être pour
démultiplier justement la présence le
présent scène lors des keynotes et puis
aussi probablement pour être plus
présents sur le terrain pour occuper
plus de terres en tout cas par rapport à
la concurrence qui fait souvent beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'annoncés on avait
l'habitude d'avoir deux annonces d'apple
la tablette d'apple d'ici qui étaient là
qui est toujours d'ailleurs la
conférence de développeurs au mois de
juin
et puis leurs grands pilotes de rentrée
au mois de septembre aux annonces et
notamment tout cas les nouveaux iphone
cette année il ya quand même beau
plus de qui note dans cette période là
septembre octobre novembre
ça c'est intéressant ça montre une
évolution de la stratégie d'apple plus
de produits plus de kinnock plus de
choses c'est cool
donc on surveillera ça de très près sur
ce je vous embrasse -11 ans a beaucoup
d'amour on se regarde ça très très vite
je les ouvre des tests vous en parle
extrêmement rapidement on décida prenez
soin de vous pour le soin de vous et de
vos proches
beaucoup d'amour et à très vite chaos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]